the british intelligence agencies have
been watching russia closely for decades
and since the ukraine war started
they've got their finger on the pulse of
the kremlin or at least that's what they
want ours and the russians to believe
only last night the head of the british
intelligence agency gchq said putin
doesn't know what's going on because his
closest colleagues aren't telling him
the truth but is all of this
disinformation my next guest says no
christopher steele thinks british spies
do have a good idea of what's going on
in russia and ukraine and he should know
because for many years he was one of
them he joins me now chris thanks so
much for joining us on the show before
we start to talk about all things
kremlin let's kick off with vitale
klitschko and that interview you just
watched it what what did you make of him
thank you for having me on the programme
beth i'm delighted to be here
i think people like vitaly klitschko
will be remembered for decades if not
centuries
as the real heroes of this period of our
history
and of ukraine of course
and a remarkable man incredibly brave
living in a city which is under siege
which he's possibly being targeted for
assassination i think we absolutely have
to take our hat off to him he smiled and
didn't answer that question but you
think he would have been targeted for
assassination without doubt i think
originally when this operation was
underwear yes definitely
so a man that really is risking his life
uh every day um let's get on to uh the
kremlin and intelligence so jeremy
fleming the boss of the
gchq said putin has made a strategic
miscalculation he said this in a speech
last night launching this invasion he
said his advisers are afraid to tell him
the truth is that your assessment too
i think that's part of the problem that
you have in an authoritarian system
where there is definitely not a premium
on passing bad news and real news back
up to the leadership however i think
there's a more fundamental point here
which is that russia has always had bad
intent in terms of rebuilding its empire
and dominating its neighbors
and it's never had the capabilities to
match that
and i think this big mistake that
putin's made in this situation of all
the mistakes and there are many
is that he believed that russia had the
capability to fulfill its intents
towards ukraine and it doesn't and and
had an ability to do that quickly and
that hasn't happened and i guess my next
question for you
is that that has clearly caused discord
in the kremlin the russian defense
minister vanished with heart problems
what's going on are they all fighting
each other
churchill once said that studying the
kremlin was like looking at bulldogs
fighting under a rug you couldn't quite
see what was going on but you could hear
the growling and the snarling and it is
very much like that and
one of the problems we've got in
assessing russia over the years is that
it's not an open society
it is it is a complex society the
leadership is not uniform it's not
monolithic but it is suppressed and the
divisions are kept behind the scenes
the fsb the russian intelligence
services though presumably they are
leaking information to the ukrainians is
that partly why the ukrainians are
fighting more effectively is that partly
why people like vitali or president
zielenski despite having
been on putin's hit list with
mercenaries in the capital that they're
still alive is that what's going on yeah
i think it's important to remember that
ukraine and russia are like england and
scotland or england and ireland and that
many russians are of ukrainian origin
and vice versa they're incredibly close
these people and therefore the site the
thought of destroying your cousin's uh
house and home and cities and after all
kiev was the first capital of the
russian state is pretty horrendous to a
lot of russians and i suspect loyalty in
that situation is very complex and
difficult
today you the uk's military chief said
that while he expects the coming weeks
to be difficult that in many ways putin
has lost do you agree with that
assessment
yes i don't see there's a way back for
putin i think this is one of the big
problems that the west is going to face
going forward i don't see how we can
trust putin in any sort of peace deal
that comes now and i don't see how we
can deal with him in terms of normal
business going forward after all the
president of america has called him a
war criminal
if you can't trust putin though in any
peace deal how does it end because
presumably it has to end with some sort
of deal i mean zelensky's talking about
neutrality and a referendum i mean
how does it end if you can't trust
anything he does and you can't negotiate
i think it does end in a deal of some
sort
um but i think that that deal is some
way off
and i think it probably doesn't include
vladimir putin um what do you mean by
that chris well i think he he may well
be pushed aside out of the top
leadership or
even possibly assassinated by his own
people
the the point is that that we've gone
over a watershed here i don't believe
there's any way back for putin i can't
believe he can be rehabilitated in the
international community and that's a big
problem for us going forward it also
means he has no incentives to stop
fighting
i think that's true unless of course
they start losing on the ground and one
of the remarkable things about this
situation now is it does look as though
the russian army at least in some areas
is being defeated and just finally on
this
um
tony radekin has said putin failed to
anticipate the unity and cohesion
amongst free nations of the world
are you worried that this western unity
would crack if donald trump returned to
power
in the u.s well that's not an immediate
prospect
actually in this situation is at least
another two to three years before
there's a presidential election in
america it certainly wouldn't help i
mean whatever one thinks of trump he was
much more of an isolationist than other
u.s presidents he questioned nato's
existence and and solidarity
and the eu and all the institutions that
stand up to russia would were put into
question by him
and chris you're a russian expert you've
studied and gathered intelligence on the
kremlin for many years you now run a
private business doing something similar
were you surprised when putin invaded
ukraine
i was surprised at the scale of the
invasion i wasn't surprised that there
was a military operation or a political
operation to recognize the breakaway
republics as independent
but i had calculated others as a
calculator the logistics of this didn't
add up
that if you cannot keep down a
population of 43 million people using
only 150 000 troops it doesn't work so
poor intelligence from the russians
i think poor advice i think poor
intelligence in terms of what i think
putin was being told which was that
parts of ukraine would welcome the
russian troops with open arms and there
was a shadow governance structure that
could be brought in to replace the
current government
and you said in your submission to the
2018 this is the intelligence and
security committee uh within parliament
that look at uh matters of national
security you said uh that russia was
becoming more aggressive that it was
moving from an authoritarian to
totalitarian state
and that uh
putin had to be tackled was the west
asleep at the wheel are we partly to
blame
for this
yes we are very largely to blame for it
in my view some of which is perhaps
understandable after 9 11 for example
there was an attempt to draw putin into
an anti-islamist alliance anti-terrorist
alliance that failed but i think
subsequently to that the problem has
been that the west has been naive about
putin and very slow to react to his
rogue state type activity
and on the issue of
how the west has reacted to putin i want
to ask you a bit about the relationship
between the uk and russia
and about oligarchs and money russian
money in london
in the uk for years you were monitoring
russia and the misdeeds of its spies
like murdering people uh in the uk
and yet you also saw british politicians
and businessmen they go into parties and
holidaying with oligarchs
do you think that the establishment here
let themselves get seduced
absolutely i think there were the two
things going on there one is a element
of naivety because many of the russians
who come to london are very urban very
convincing very sort of westernized
they don't represent the real russia if
you like there is a dark side to russia
which not many people understand sadly
i've been studying it for the last 20
years
um but i also think in addition to that
russian money a wall of money that hit
london it wasn't just russian but it was
russian money first i think
sort of set up a lobby a group of
interests who
serviced this elite who the lawyers the
estate agents the pr firms and so on and
it became a pretty important part of our
economy and i suspect also in terms of
investment and so on particularly after
brexit and what have you when we were
looking for other forms of investment in
the country this golden visa scheme
which is now so controversial and in
retrospect was such a bad mistake grows
out of that problem
and there is one person that's
particularly being talked about lately
which is evgeny lebvedev you said an
interview with skye last october with
sky news it was curious mr johnson boris
johnson had enabled the son of a kgb
officer now it's important that i make
it clear lord levitate is a british
citizen has broken no laws has condemned
the war in ukraine and strongly denies
any insinuation he's sympathetic to the
russian government
but
his elevation to the laws has been
controversial would you like to see the
intelligent reports
around the decision to make him a lord
and put him into the house of lords
yes there's a parliamentary procedure
involved here which is quite complicated
and i do understand needs for
confidentiality and so on but this is
such a controversial appointment and the
story out there is that it was against
the advice of the security services so i
think it's a pretty exceptional case and
there was a debate in parliament the
other day and i think probably the
outcome of that should be more
transparency about how this decision was
made
you have some experience would you think
that
that has credibility that the security
services would have been anxious
about
disappointment
i think any sort of family member of a
former kgb
officer or a kgb agent and
actually
lebedev is not the only one there are
quite a few former kgb officers who are
quite prominent in britain and in
business here who need to be very
closely looked at and certainly it's
surprising to me that they've managed to
operate in the country's country in the
way that they have well it is now
changing of course with these huge
sanctions against a number
of different people and companies
can i now bring you just to the world of
spies
because
is it fair to say that people are right
not to trust intelligence sources it's
often disinformation you often use
anonymous sources
yet we're all expected to be reverential
about british intelligence do you accept
that you offer us no truth or proof in
anything you say
i think that's an exaggeration clearly
intelligence work is as much an art form
as it is a science and what you're
trying to do in intelligence work always
is to
test out a piece of information
get it from different sources get it
from different types of sources i think
that actually the calling out of this
invasion by western intelligence has
been a remarkable operation and i think
that
the the decision to preempt
to make intelligence public in this
situation to preempt russian activity
has wrong-footed the kremlin quite a lot
that that was interesting wasn't it
because what happened was things like
the invasion the planning of it then you
know the threat of chemical weapons
what's happened is western leaders who
would typically keep that all private
have been shouting about it and making
it public what's the tactic of doing
that
it's the information warfare i mean the
reason that intelligence often isn't
made public is obviously because of the
need to protect sources and techniques
and every time you make a piece of
intelligence public you are taking
certain risks in that regard however in
this situation where you're dealing with
a strategic threat the invasion of a
european country by russia the decision
was obviously taken that that risk was
worth taking and i think it's paid off
but it's fair to say as well that
british intelligence officers would also
deal in disinformation as russians would
right
it depends how what you're talking about
i mean if you're saying that we should
be
spreading this information to russian
troops on the battlefield in ukraine
probably yes if you're talking about
disinformation about our own society
obviously not
and chris how does this end you you've
said that you
think that putin there's no way back for
him that there would have to be some
sort of regime change
in russia although how that could happen
still pretty opaque
klitschko said in that interview
that he was worried or he warned europe
the rest of europe
uh that there is a danger that this tips
into a wider european
war
do you agree with that are you fearful
about that
yes i think
people talk in terms of this being like
munich in 1938 1939
it's probably equally
threatening in terms of 1914 where we
sort of slipped into war by various
mistakes and smaller countries provoking
bigger countries and so on so there's
always a risk that something like this
can spread and you know the polls are
very robust they've talked about having
ukrainian fighter aircraft uh in their
country or provided from their country
so it's very important that nato remains
united
everyone sticks to the same script
everyone sticks to the same rules about
this in order to prevent this conflict
spreading okay chris i've got more
questions for you but i have run out of
time as ever thank you so much uh for
joining us